okay so welcome to the second part
of this year's kendrew lectures
and uh
the second lecture will be given by john
jumper
and
john got his bachelor's degree in
mathematics and physics from
vanderbilt
and it was followed by an m phil from
cambridge
where he worked on condensed matter
theory
i have to confess i spent some time
doing the same thing and eventually
departed in the same
way
he then he then worked for three years
at d e shaw's uh research institute in
new york city uh and worked actually his
co-authored uh papers with d e shaw
where he first started working on
molecular dynamics of proteins
and then went on to do his phd
at the university of chicago and
applying machine learning to protein
folding
and dynamics
since 2017 has been a research scientist
at deepmind where he's now the research
lead on the alpha fold project
and so uh in this lecture is going to
tell us about the details of the alpha
fold program
and hopefully
plans for the future
of alpha fold and related areas so john
thank you so much
it's uh it's been really wonderful to be
here and also to hear about uh all the
amazing work uh
that's that's done here and really
excited about both the work that's
enabled by alpha fault and to hear about
the work that very definitely isn't
and uh really excited about what the
future will break but let me
let me tell you a little bit about um
how alpha fold is made kind of peel into
some of the layers
of what makes this work how
it understands structure some of the
things that is able to do some of the
things that isn't
and maybe try and give um
some sort of
notion in which how did this how does
this program understand structure which
parts doesn't it
and really
where do we think this will lead in the
future and we think and i always think
that alpha fold is kind of two things
it's a software program that produces
accurate protein structures you put in a
sequence and the structure that comes
out at the end is accurate often in many
ways
but then it's also a set of ideas and
kind of
how we build neural networks around
proteins
and those ideas we think will impact
many more problems and new ideas to come
that we're really going to look back on
this
as saying well this was kind of
structured prediction of single change
is kind of the first thing that we were
able to do with these tools
but that these ideas and methods will
grow and really start to reshape how we
investigate biological systems and so by
way of introduction and certainly uh
with dumas great talk and probably even
before you've heard about kind of the
results that casp and both the
the progress that we were able to make
and the um
and the kind of results and on systems
both
you know small and very important like
or fate from stars cove two
and very large systems like the rna
polymerase
on the left well maybe not very large in
the scale biological assembly but very
large in the scale of
of protein structure prediction
and i want to really say again
that casp and this notion that
we're going to get everyone together and
we're going to really see which
computational methods work and we're not
going to rely on individual
people to hopefully run the same set of
experiments or to not accidentally
include the
test set of proteins in the training set
that we're going to really treat this as
a real problem with the cooperation of
the experimental community and measure
every two years how the whole field is
doing to understand what works and
doesn't has really really been an
institutional important
part both in terms of the historical
development and understanding where it
is and i would also encourage you all to
read the papers that have come out from
the casp assessors who talk in detail
about the results and what they may mean
and so
similarly we
have not only put out after we built the
system open source code but we've taken
this attempt at you know folding all the
structures
of
humans and 21
and 20 other model organisms we have
plans to expand this to approximately
uniref 90 to cover full space and we
think that this will drive us into this
really really interesting regime
in which uh
structure becomes abundant
and a really interesting
question and kind of research is how
will research change
as you know it used to be that the line
between genomics and structure is that
pde is that uniprot grew
uh three thousand times faster than the
pdb in terms of number of depositions
and so we're at this the genomics
revolution had given us really sequence
abundance
and alpha fold as a tool to turn that
into structural abundance and so now i
think we'll see this interesting regime
where we start to see what new science
can be done in the era of structural
abundance in terms of homology in terms
of understanding species in terms
of understanding human biology and we
think
that really this is kind of an exciting
and transformational thing
that will
change our relationship to structure and
biology
but to dig into how it works
and i think the kind of core point i
want to make at the beginning
is that we have known a lot about
protein structure for a long time thanks
to some incredible biophysics work
by a large number of biophysicists a lot
about evolutionary biology we've really
understood you know quite a lot of facts
about proteins
but what we've lacked is an ability to
synthesize those into the right
structure
that it wasn't so obvious it's not a
simple equation
that finds say the minimum free energy
structure um and really and when we
started this work
and when we started with alpha fold one
we were doing what was a common approach
in the field where we would have a
component that was built out of neural
networks
but that was really an off-the-shelf
system from computer vision
and then right it was exactly the same
type of thing that you might do for
image for
image recognition
and then around it we built all our
protein knowledge and we we put the
amino acids here and kind of
optimization of the chain there and kind
of we wanted to build the protein
structural knowledge around the deep
learning system
and without the fold two what we had
started to do
almost immediately was to say no no this
belongs inside the network that this
will be
this is the main component we need this
to understand proteins now how do we
take what we understand about proteins
and build it into the core components of
the network how do we build pieces that
want to learn about proteins so that
when we show it the incredibly valuable
data from the pdb which is inherently
limited right it's not it's not normal
to do machine learning where every data
point represents a phd's worth of effort
right this is very very very different
from image recognition how do we think
about how we build these insights into
the structure of our network
um and we talk about some specific ones
and i'll talk about some specific ones
in the talk
but we needed to build a kind of neural
network technology of proteins and that
turned out to be extremely extremely
efficient
and so this goes in kind of a long line
of research
in machine learning and in
neural networks that
uses this jargony term inductive bias
that there are certain problems that are
easier depending on how you connect your
neural network how you build the
individual pieces and you see this very
very prominently in the enormous success
of what are called convolutional
networks and these are
like convolutions and image processing
operate on a very small patch of an
image
and build that up the analogy and
proteins is things that operate on a
very local patch of sequence
and so this was how alpha one was built
was around these convolutional ideas and
then you build more and more and you
hope that it learns higher level
structure
and that reflects well the primary
sequence the notion of kind of local
linear motifs but it represents very
very poorly the 3d spatial structure
that at least at the end of this process
things that are 200 amino acids apart
may be right next to each other must be
right next to each other
and so
if you think about things that are
oriented around say very very local
things like convolutions
or recurrent networks then you're not
really capturing that aspect of spatial
structure or geometry
there's been also a lot of great work on
graph networks things that embed in this
notion of connectivity but the problem
is you must start with the answer if you
knew everything that was close to each
other you wouldn't need alpha fold
um
and so we based it around these ideas in
attention networks so this is a
technology that's become very very
powerful recently
where you in essence allow the neural
network to build its own connections of
different strengths between different
parts of the chain and what we observe
in alpha fold is that as it learns about
structure it will start to build the
connections of the pieces of structure
it knows
and so this gives it really natural
connections
uh between the pieces of stroke between
the piece of structure it built and we
originally start we said okay we'll put
in attention and this will be the right
language and the kind of off-the-shelf
attention networks didn't really work at
all for this
we didn't get an understanding we were
missing quite a bit more we had one
right notion that there should be some
notion of spontaneous connection that
develops within the network but we were
missing lots of other notions of
geometry or how does evolution fit into
this prediction and everything else
and so
we really needed to go back also to this
kind of picture and i liked this picture
that has emerged especially well the
picture is very much older than the
structure prediction community but that
it is important for structure prediction
and if you think about the causality of
protein structure and every evolution
and everything else there's a very
causal direction the sequence causes the
structure right that's what entrance and
said
um and via physics and then we all know
that the function causes the patterns of
evolution by preserving function and
that structure changes slowly over
evolutionary time
and so the causal direction is kind of
that the structure causes the fun causes
the evolutionary history or at least the
patterns observed across evolutionary
history and so evolutionary structure
prediction is to to kind of be bayesian
to run the causality in the wrong way
and to take this pile of evolution or to
take the natural sequences uh that you
can find via evolution and say well what
protein structure must they explain
and here this turns out to be very
powerful and not um kind of in the way
that had been done before and the very
literalist will build the evolutionary
correlations and then we'll correct for
the direct versus indirect coupling
effects but rather a more general method
where we present this as another useful
piece of information that the
multi-sequence alignments that we can
collect should tell us quite a lot about
the structure
by reversing the causality arrow
and so when we start from the input
sequence from the for the protein we use
very standard tools jackhammer and hh
blitz to look up a multi-sequence
alignment the evolutionary history
and just really present that as a raw
piece of information for our neural
network and so
throughout alpha fold and there was a
very interesting question when talking
to students about what are the roles of
templates for example which we also
look up i'll talk
and
we pass in we make
templates for example we pull also from
structured databases and we present them
just as input
and
that goes essentially that's presented
as if it may be interesting to the
network rather than as something you
thread over
but maybe the really important part is
in the middle and i'll see if i can i
can't use that
but in the middle where you see the
residue pairs
and here this represents almost nothing
at the beginning we put no information
at the start of the network it's more or
less the sequence distance of each pair
and some other very minor information it
knows very little about the structure
unless uh except when the templates tell
it
but at the beginning this is encoding a
notion of kind of physics or aligning
with physics that we know that physics
is largely pairwise that we know that
interactions are very important
spatially and so we build this structure
in
of pairwise terms that we hope that the
network will ultimately use
in order to think about residue pairs
and then as we start to build our
architecture and we really kind of put
the templates into the pairs we're
missing an arrow there but as we think
about
this we start with very raw information
here are the sequences in the
multi-sequence alignment
here are all the pairs of residues and
then we're going to put this through a
block that we call evoformer that we had
built especially for this task
that starts to process this data and
makes newer richer more refined forms
and i really haven't told you how it
processes much and i'll tell you
only a bit because the important point
is really because of this principle of
indian training is what happens at the
end
so you see after we process it through
something i haven't told you much about
we produced these very refined um
representations of the multi-sequence
alignment
and of the pairs of residues and then we
put them into what we call the structure
module
and this is um
a module that we made to really encode
the fact that we are doing 3d geometry
and so it has explicit notions that
every entity is a residue with a
position and an orientation
and
this operates in 3d space and builds
that final structure that you see and of
course at the start of training it
builds a very terrible structure it will
look nothing like a protein in fact it
won't even have a connected primary
sequence
um
but we can now compare this to an
experimental structure in the pdb
and find a direction to improve it just
a bit
and so what we do is we back propagate
so we start
from an error in that structure and then
we correct each part of this to be
slightly to give a slightly better
answer and do that iteratively and so
what gives meaning to this pair
representation
um
so it starts with a bit of meaning it
looks like residue pairs but it gains
more meaning at the end because we use
it in a very specific way at the very
end we'll ask each individual pixel at
the ij location what is the distance
between residue i and residue j
and we will produce that as an output so
in the course of this neural network we
basically build the blocks around what
we want to communicate how we want
information to exchange
and then at the end of the neural
network we give them meaning by asking
them a very specific question
and because we've trained this
end-to-end
you can ask really complex questions
like what is the structure
and then you can find all the different
places back in the network where you can
tweak a little bit to do better and if
you do this
a million times in a row you actually
end up with a very very strong system
and then we add to it an extra notion
where we're really trying to push it
around refinement so one
kind of notion that is a little bit
missing in here
is that you know you want when you're
predicting a structure it's often the
case you'll know certain things you'll
be able to build pieces of the structure
and then you need to build
more newer pieces
and so what we will do is we'll take the
answer from this network and what we
call recycle it we will push
that back through the network a second
and a third and a fourth time
which tends to produce a bit better
answer and each time it's trying to
improve its answer and so this is a bit
also like self-templating the network
one useful template that you may want to
use is your answer from a previous round
and out of that we also pull additional
outputs of course the confidence the
plddt that demos talked about as well as
this pairwise confidence of predicted
align error and this will tell you this
is something you can look up online how
to do it but we'll tell you when you
should trust the domain packing
structure especially of this network
but to kind of dig into the ideas and i
think i really want to dig into one of
the core ideas
of
evil form or even some of the core and
it's really important before we go into
that to note kind of what parts of what
we did mattered
and so if you look at this table
and
this is the gdt that's a measure of
structure accuracy
difference each line of each row of this
table represents a separately trained
alpha fold model
trained from scratch from the paper for
the paper
almost exactly the same as the alpha
fold that we used in casp except
self-distillation training which was
more expensive we treated it as an
addition rather than a subtraction
but each one of these says if you remove
some idea and train a new network
how well do you do and you can see
almost all the ideas removing them is
bad
right
uh across eight or ten ideas in fact the
one of the closest to not being paid is
uh
to uh remove templates the model is
really very insensitive to template in
most cases
um
but
what's important to say is that all of
these pieces represent different ways in
which we try to align how we built this
neural network and the individual pieces
of the neural network with our
understanding of protein structure and
all of it mattered to some degree and it
starts to matter non-linearly so each of
these are much much smaller differences
than say the difference between
our cast alpha fold model and any other
model that was entered into the
competition that would be more like 30
20 or 30 on this baseline
um
but what we see is that all these ideas
added some and in combination was
extremely powerful but the important
part was really
kind of the methodology of doing this
alignment the details matter and it
really sat at the intersection of
understanding of protein kind of physics
and geometry and biology together with
uh understanding ml and networks and
that's one of the reasons that deepmind
was such a great place to do this work
is that the there's a really wonderful
computational problem that sits squarely
at the interface
between these techniques and so to give
an example kind of a little vignette of
some of the ideas that we put in so this
is one that's quite beautiful called
triangular attention so if you remember
that matrix is supposed to represent all
pairs of residues
and so
we have methods in which we are
exchanging information between them or
between two elements and you can think
of an element as representing an ij pair
so if you exchange information across a
row you will exchange an ij pair
and maybe an ik pair
and each of those you can think of as
two legs of the triangle or if you
if you want to think about the distance
between them is what this network
represents
then there's a missing piece right that
the relationship between i and j and
i and k
are is very strongly determined also by
the relationship between j and k this is
say a geometric point of view the
triangle inequality
says that um
i guess it labeled here is uh a b and c
but if two if a and b are close and a
and c are closed and b and c must also
be close
and so rather than try and put this in
in a very handcrafted way to say this
must exactly represent a distance and we
shall push the triangle inequality into
it
we built in triangular communication and
we built the new piece that i won't go
into the details where the network
updates itself with many many small
triangles of residues
and we find that
by adding this kind of communication
pattern rather than a hard-coded rule we
do observe much stronger obeyance of the
triangle inequality by the final output
of the network and we notice uh an
increase a small increase in accuracy
and so and i should say by the way the
the pairwise distance prediction obey
the triangle inequality obviously all
coordinates must because they're in
space
but
we can start to build in kind of these
notions we know but in interesting and
exciting ways and figure out how to
build that into the structure of the
network and the learning system so that
was kind of a very physical and proper
thing we thought about a good physical
geometric fact we put it into our
network and we felt good about it um the
structure module is an example of the
opposite we're going to do something
horrible and then we'll feel bad about
it
so we're going to start from the
sequence of the chain
and looking at individual residues
represented here by triangles position
and orientation
we know that there's a very very strong
restraint that you can think of this in
terms of the ramachandran angles of the
backbone
but this is a very very bad
representation to work with in neural
networks in a lot of ways
because
thinking about all those individual
twists like if you have a pro if you
have for example a split domain that
goes off for hundreds of residues and
comes back
then if you think about it in the kind
of natural
torsional space the natural ramachandran
space
then you have kind of a 200 or a couple
hundred residue excursion to get back to
a couple angstrom interaction
and that's quite terrible so we just we
just kind of ignore that
and so we treat each individual residue
we call it a residue gas
and
we treat each one as a freely optimized
thing and you can if you look carefully
over the iterations in which we optimize
this within the structure module you can
see it kind of has an unphysical
breathing and the helices look a little
bit too big at the beginning and some
other things and what you're really
seeing here is that we're ignoring a
good proper uh biophysics fact in order
to make it easy for the network to
optimize all pieces simultaneously and
so over the course of training it
observes that i and i plus 1 residues
are always in this geometry consistent
with the peptide bond but we treat that
as a learned fact to allow the network
to optimize and so in this sense we're
kind of trading proper biophysics for
computational expediency
and so making these kinds of decisions
or what enable ultimately this network
which does a very surprising thing it
has
a hundred in total 192 blocks of
computation
and uh for protein of almost any size at
least out to the couple maybe 3 000
residues that we've tested it with
it proceeds in a finite number of steps
to build this structure
right this is very unreasonable from
kind of a physical folding point of view
where protein folding times depend on
transition state energies and are highly
variable here we're saying you have 90
192 blocks and so we have to put in
these kind of
things that favor the
computer science aspects of it the
parallelism
over maybe the physical aspects and so
working through all of these and if you
pull these types of constraints
correctly this is part of what builds
the system that understands proteins
and enables the learning to occur so in
another way to think about this is that
deepmind is about building very general
learning systems and there's quite a lot
we don't understand about proteins and
we kind of say well the network will
have to understand it there's some
things that we understand well
that we can kind of build into
especially not exactly hard-coded rules
but how we exchange information to
enable this type of learning to occur
now
we also have observed something really
really interesting
in terms of thinking about the pdb it's
a wild place it contains the combined
output of the entire structural biology
community which includes everything from
exciting ligands to post-translational
modifications to all sorts of weird and
wild things and the neural network is
trained on all of them and is presented
only with the primary sequence of one of
the chains and so it has to be because
this is such an unspecified problem the
neural network has to be tolerant to
under specified conditions right it
can't fail on every protein that has an
obligate aim just because we didn't tell
it there's a heave and so we do observe
actually
quite strongly something that looks like
at least tolerance and maybe even
um kind of knowledge of
pieces of structure that are not
specified so on the left you see a zinc
binding site where we don't predict the
zinc this is overlaid from the crystal
but the side chain geometries are
perfect
uh for the zinc
we also see uh very commonly on
homomeric proteins that the model will
in fact
uh even though alpha fold
was only predicting one of these chains
we just overlaid on the trimeric
structure it produced a highly
intertwined trimer in a configuration
that makes no sense for a single chain
because it had to do that it saw a
tremendous number of homomeric proteins
in the pdb so it had to have some
ability to reason over this missing
context
we can go further in trying to
understand what the network kind of
thinks about structure and so much as it
it thinks and the way we do this the way
we try to kind of peel open the black
box
is to take a trained alpha fold network
which is called frozen right we're not
going to change it but then for every
layer of the network
we have this we are going to ask it to
produce its answer right now and we
train
48 individual predictors at every point
in the network go
and predict the structure as of that
moment and so you can think of this as a
way to manifest alpha folds belief about
structure at that moment
and when you do that you see some really
interesting patterns and this is orphan
which is one of the most challenging uh
one of the more challenging proteins
that alpha fold has predicted the
structure of successfully and what you
see over the individual layers obviously
it figures out the secondary structure
quite quickly but you see something that
looks almost pseudodynamical right i you
know quite reminded me other than the
very early layers of what i had seen in
molecular dynamics is it starts to fit
and pull pieces together and as it
obtains the correct geometry it tends to
lock it into place
but we see a lot of evidence
that alpha fold is kind of exploring
with a very concrete structural
hypothesis
and then
building and maintaining the parts of
that hypothesis that are true that are
reinforced probably by all the
interactions
and if we look at this and you can see a
very unphysical structure at the
beginning obviously but if you look at
this on a very large 2000 residue chain
you can see that some domains are built
very early and then some are built very
late and presumably refined against the
kind of information
that has been discovered in intermediate
layers
and when we go and we look at
predictions of distance for example
we'll see some pieces of structure
emerge confidently and then we'll see
the kind of neural network information
exchange will happen exactly over
residues that it knows or close in space
whereas where when it doesn't know where
residue is you'll see much more diffuse
information transfer
and so
we have in the system and something that
we didn't quite really build in right
certainly not over the individual layers
is a kind of iterative learning that it
is
kind of searching kind of building at
each stage on its piece of knowledge
and doing it in a way that's reliable
and what would really go wrong if you
try and do this by hand is that you
would make wrong decisions and be unable
to correct them and the network seems
relatively robust that over the course
of its evolution it's something we're
still digging quite a bit more into and
you can see these are this the
representation the y-axis is the
structure accuracy and the x-axis is the
um
this is actually teaching ordering four
is a slightly different protein that was
very easy and you can see for very easy
proteins very early in the network alpha
fold gives a correct structure and
sticks with it whereas for a very
difficult uh protein like orphan which
is uh labeled t1064 because that was
what it was in casp you can see that it
requires many many layers in order to
come up with the structure and in fact
probably we stopped a bit early at 192
and so this is the mechanism that we
have for what we call recycling is
basically a way to give the network more
time to think about very difficult
proteins
and so this and we're starting to see
kind of this iterative process that has
emerged spontaneously within alpha fold
and starting to make us think about how
we should build the next generation of
systems
now the impact of alpha fold i mean i i
i feel a little bit bad about trying to
tell structural biologists about this
because really i'm learning from
structural biologists about this
but um
[Music]
one of the things that i
we want to talk about and as we decided
to fold the human proteome
um
it was it was a very exciting thing and
we were very
unsure about exactly how much we would
add to the structural cultures right the
human proteome was extremely well
studied
but we do see um as dimma said about a
doubling if you compare the
experimentally known structures to now
the high confidence structures here the
grave land represents anything with a
strong template and so this represents
even more what you might expect to do
very well on by template modeling and
you can still see quite uh large
increases in coverage in both the high
with both the very high and high
confidence bands
so even across an organism like human
we're seeing a large increase in
structural coverage and i would point
out especially
uh the integral component of membrane
proteins alpha fold is in general as
accurate on membrane proteins as it is
on globular proteins um often the
evolutionary signal is very very strong
in membrane proteins so we add a
particularly large amount of coverage to
that class as would be expected
and i'll talk about a little bit later
why these bars don't go all the way to
the right why the the high confidence
residues or even medium and low
confidence don't cover the entire chain
and the rest of it is very low
confidence
but it's also we're saying that alpha
fold has had this really incredible
impact in terms of enhancing
experimental structure determination
that we've been very excited about
and on the right is a
a hemp domain solved by andre lupis's
group and this was actually
in cast but at the time they entered in
cast they didn't know
the structure and they had 10 year old
x-ray data sitting on their shelf
and so it was the cast organizers
thought it would be an appropriate
challenge to really it's so blind the
experimentalists don't know the
structure and alpha fold was able to
produce a quite good model you can see
in green and phase these phase these
data
we're also seeing this having an impact
in cryo-em especially the low-resolution
cryorium this is the ar-9 from the ar9
complex of peter layman's group
and uh here what we're really seeing is
exciting things where alpha fold is kind
of a very nice complement to cryo-em
because there are a lot of medium or low
resolution regions that alpha fold can
give really really high
uh can
really give atomistic detail to this in
addition to some really exciting work
and i don't have it in the deck from
people like tristan kroll is that this
amazing thing of using alpha fold for
proteins of unknown sequence but he
determined the sequence uh from a cryo
density and some other things really
exciting work and we're even starting to
see this in nmr and uh guy montenegro
and others that have worked on how alpha
fold structures can be used for nmr peak
assignment and to improve nmr coordinate
determination and so it's really
exciting to us
um both for kind of the immediacy of the
feedback of you know this was we've
definitely got it correct there's little
doubt on either of these um certainly
there's no doubt in molecular
replacement but also
um the ability that these kind of work
synergistically that we are using this
to learn about more and more complex
biological systems and certainly will
become increasingly important in the era
of these amazing priorium complexes
but the other part of the story the
missing part right
why
why does alpha fold not give confident
structures for everything and i will say
one of the scariest parts for us is when
we first started
folding or predicting the structure of
random proteins from uniprot and random
immune proteins is they looked a lot
worse than the things that we predicted
from pdb
right and this i i don't think would
have been too much news to
experimentalist but it was
terrifying to us on how many large
terribly ugly segments we would have
kind of like the ones at the bottom
right for that protein
and this made us worry very much that
maybe alpha fold was
possibly the results were more special
the kinds of things that are already
easy to structurally determine
um
but then we started to really notice
that when we looked at the regions that
had very low confidence they
corresponded quite well to uniprot
disorder annotations and in fact if you
look at the bottom left and you can see
on resolved residues in pdb a very high
percentage or high confidence and you
know a lot of pdb has strong templates
but still very very few say
predicted confidence less than 50 which
is a quite low number whereas if you
look at the unresolved regions of pdb
structures there's a very high
percentage
of
plddt less than 50 alpha fold was very
unconfident and even some of the places
which are high confident some of those
may be mistakes but some of those may
also be regions that one resolves a due
to domain motion
and when we look at the human protein we
see something in between
and so we started to realize and think
and want to measure to winston is alpha
fold saying i'm not sure i'm very unsure
really how much does that mean that
there's simply not a structure to find
and
really
in many cases it will turn out to be
true and we believe for example that you
can identify the domains of the protein
in the bottom right but the ones in
between we don't expect to be deposited
in pdb certainly in a nice globular
structure now a certain kind of caveat
to that notice note is that
disorder means many things and we use in
the paper unstructured in isolation you
can see example in the top
right where alpha fold correctly
predicts the domain
um of this chain blue would be the alpha
fold prediction green would be the
experimental structure
but we would have we have very low
confidence on the
coil region that goes across it but of
course this is resolved in pdb because
it's wrapped around another domain and
so this is something we would call
unstructured in isolation but that
doesn't mean it will never appear in pdb
in any form it's just not going to be
kind of a globular well-formed structure
and we're really interested in
understanding those i'll talk about some
work at the end
and we can go ahead and quantitatively
measure that left was from the paper
where we looked at precision and recall
of certain thresholds on how much you
should believe that this indicates your
protein is disordered we saw quite good
numbers but we're obviously not experts
in disorder prediction and out after the
alpha fold paper came out um some really
great work by uh mazzaros and norman
davey
uh showed that really actually alpha
fold is a very strong disorder
prediction so it's a slightly complex
graph on the right but if you look at
the purple line that would be a very
commonly used disorder predictor io pred
2
alpha fold
various alpha fold drive measures that
they did are the other curves and you
can see a much much more favorable uh
area under the curve for precision
recall now we don't we want to be
cautious here that io cred is not
is a very fast disorder predictor but
it's not the most accurate this needs
more benchmarking and work is ongoing
but we think it's quite promising and we
think it's a really really good sign
that at least
on well-studied organism classes that
it's very likely that alpha full lack of
confidence is a very good sign for
disorder
now
the other kind of point that was very
very obvious is that
single chain structure prediction has
quite a lot of limits and so we really
wanted to move
and go toward alpha fold for complexes
and this would work we've actually done
starting before
uh even the paper came out
but it was interestingly as soon as the
paper came out there was some work you
know there's the proper way in which you
retrain alpha folding short protein
complexes and you expect this to do well
but it turns out that this
the single chain alpha fold
actually is surprisingly good at
predicting especially homomeric but also
heteromeric interfaces and this was um
kind of announced in the scientific
community in a series of tweets
from ming kyungbak and
[Music]
from yoshitaka
and they basically said that there's two
different methods adding a gap or even
adding just a disordered linker sequence
is enough to make alpha fold sometimes
produce very confident complexes
predictions and
and some more
analysis out of barney oldest group uh
claims that probably this is
the currently available state of the art
in complex prediction
is simply to say is to try and trick
alpha fold into thinking it's one long
chain
right and this is a really kind of
interesting and emergent property and i
think it points to
kind of alpha folders and aligned in the
right way
right if you think about the fold as a
memorization system this is very very
confusing because
it's never seen a complex in its life
now it has probably i guess you could
say it's seen proteins that perhaps got
fused at some point in evolutionary
history or split in evolutionary history
but still
you would be relatively surprised that
it can do these things but it is aligned
with kind of the physics of interfaces
the geometry everything else and we
think even for this it's not even using
any type of co-evolutionary signal based
on the way the inputs are constructed
and yet because of the way we built this
neural network it has this understanding
that also is the same type of physics
that drives um
individual protein uh domains and
multi-domain interactions are the same
type of physics that drive complexes and
so this was really interesting
but um
we also had work coming out and this was
work that came out i guess last week
where we released the system where we
had adapted alpha fault so we changed
the inputs the multi-domain complexes
the training in terms of how we present
uh complex now presenting and how we
emphasize the complex interfaces the
loss basically neural network and
training details and trained essentially
the same alpha fold architecture from
scratch on complexes and obtained you
can see on the left
a much stronger system this is docq
which is a metric of docking quality
much stronger than linker gap-based
these types of hacks regular alpha-fold
systems and starting to produce and
these are cherry-picked examples but
some
really compelling examples of complexes
in fact even uh
talking before and with the with the
link for the i think the gap version
people have seen really compelling
complexes but we think this is
quite a bit more accurate and diving
into the accuracy we find actually only
a bit more interestingly a bit more
accurate on homomeric proteins
um but on our test set um quite a bit
more accurate on heteromeric
interactions and with this interface ptm
which is a good confidence measure now
this is still i would say this has more
limitations
not just known stoichiometry
sadly it performs poorly on antibody
interactions we believe we need to
assess that more we don't yet know why
but also um i'd say one of the biggest
differences in kind of use from alpha
fold is alfalfa fold says it doesn't
know the structure that's probably
because there isn't one that's not at
all true for this system so we will
still miss quite a few interactions we
expect
and so this is an area which we think
things will improve rapidly
so what's next and there are there are
many many things next but i wanted to
point out kind of three really big
classes of challenges
um
one is to extend alpha fold to you know
the other major areas of well structure
and structure prediction we want to
increase multimeric accuracy and there's
already great work out of the baker lab
on interactions but to really start
thinking about getting to a complete
interaction map
we want to think about nucleic acids and
ligand interactions
as well as possibly rna structure and of
course conformational diversity i mean
one of the big limitations we have no
control over whether alpha make alpha
fold makes an apo or a holo structure
you know in many many cases
there should be enough data in the
functional in the pdb to at least pick
out a lot of functional states you know
roland dunbrack did a great analysis of
what we produced on kinases and we
produced a nice mix of dfgn and dfg out
but we should be producing both of those
for all the kinases right and so
these kinds of things we're not yet
there but we think that this is
something that can be extended in the
same sort of ideas and maybe one or two
more will be needed
um
what we're calling the structural
meadoprodio
that when we have 100 million
structures
what are we going to do with it and what
are we going to do in the era of
structural abundance and one of the
answers will be that bioinformatics
will surely at least at least the
for things that are encoding regions
will become part of structure you'll
always have the choice to use structure
in bioinformatics
but we think there'll be new tools and
ways of thinking and how do we think
about having 100 million structures with
high reliability and we think that this
will lead to new areas of investigation
and science and everything else
and then finally alpha fold is not
sensitive to point mutations it it finds
the functionally encoded structure
and so you know questions about how do
we think about changes in structure and
stability upon point mutation how do we
think about binding affinity and
exchanges how do we think about
post-translational modification its
effect on the structure
all of these are really really important
uh areas for future work and we think
really starting to push outward this
beachhead we've got into computational
tools that give really really powerful
predictions on these systems
and so with that i want to make
acknowledgments and i want to say you
know both the large the teams that them
has pointed to that worked on the
methods and the human proteome and
especially uh imble and its partnership
and is responsible for kind of a lot of
the great things in how we present this
data and how we think about you know
displaying disordered regions that i
think is really shifting some of the
conversation even in how people
think about their proteins in terms of
these disordered regions that they're
right up in your face
and um
they've been really really great
partners in making this work available
to the community and uh with that i'll
take questions
[Music]
thank you
great talk
questions
yeah thanks great talk i guess my
question is a pretty obvious one but i
um
how and
i like how you do you plan to overcome
the limitations of basing your network
on
evolutionary and uh sequence
data that is that when will alpha paul
become a universal protein folding
predictor could you
do you envision it predicting uh
proteins that have unnatural amino acids
for example
i think they're i think it's a really
good question i think there's a couple
different ways to think about it and
certainly my own thinking of this
evolved over the project because i came
out of the biophysics community and i
said proteins
fold due to physics we should do that
just right um obviously we didn't
exactly in in that way
and but i think one important well
there's two points one is
for kind of most natural proteins
genomic coverage is not an obstacle
like for basically no proteins that
appear in casp of 100 proteins and you
can so you can find cases and i think
when you get to understudied organisms
or things that come out of metagenomics
maybe this will be a larger issue but
for a lot of natural proteins it's not
an issue
i think
and i think for getting kind of
this overall like one angstrom fold in
most cases that's not an issue where it
really becomes a deep and very very
important issue
is when you get into multiple states and
then you want to assess
really phase transitions or the
energetic the delta delta the delta g's
and delta delta g's between them
right and i think when my kind of
biophysicist picture
of mutations is that they don't change
the structure but they do change the
overall free energy of that particular
basin
uh but that overall free energy is
dependent on lots of other factors that
alpha fold doesn't know about it's you
know ph dependent it's salt dependent
it's all the other things dependent and
so
when you want to get to a system that's
really kind of qualitatively telling you
that it's shifting between these two you
have to say under what conditions maybe
you can say before that okay well this
is causing this delta delta g of this
state
and then you also have to talk about
well okay well this state exists and
that state exists these are the two that
we're comparing and i think
post-translational modifications will be
largely the same way
now you you can think of it in some ways
an induced conformational change but
you're all you're almost kind of judging
states that exist now some of them exist
at a positive free energy and you don't
see them but that's kind of how i think
so i think you will have to get into as
dennis talks about this more physical
energetic picture
in order to
answer the biological questions you
really had yes the structure is
different as deposited in pdb
but that's really due to a quite small
shift in a very finely balanced delta g
in my view
great talk john i was wondering is there
any way
the tools you've built could be used the
other way around if i want to design a
protein of a given
structure perhaps even function could
you provide me with a sequence
so there's been
quite a lot of work external to deep
mind related to this
so
yes or at least it can contribute to it
doesn't directly and immediately solve
it but what you can see so what we do
know first of all if you take any design
sequence that appears in pdb alpha 4
normally gives a very very good
structure prediction for it with no
multi-sequence alignment no templates
because the sequence is
very very clear toward the structure
um
there's been other work and can we
optimize and can we make a sequence that
alpha fold thinks has this structure and
then will it actually have this
structure
um i think even some work went on work
with computational validation went on
archive about that maybe today maybe
yesterday but um and there's also been
work on kind of back propagating through
a neural network the kind of
hallucination results
i think that certainly alpha-4 will do a
better job or very likely alpha fold
will be an improvement in those kind of
systems that use a structure predictor
in the middle
i don't expect that alone will solve all
problems immediately
right so alpha fold isn't normally in
the same ways off fold is not normally a
stability is not a stability predictor
right it doesn't pick up point
mutational effects that's an obstacle to
these types of things although not a
complete obstacle and so i think i think
it will be intermediate but i think it
will enable kind of the net it will be
i'll also say the kind of learning
systems that you put into that
probably you should put in the
architecture that alpha fold uses right
so the kind of neural network ideas will
carry over straight quite
straightforwardly using alpha fold as a
subcomponent of the system and kind of
two dimensions
point is moving away from this end in
learning and just saying let's well
we'll just put a component that we built
beforehand and so that's somewhat of the
opposite direction it will certainly
help and there's been some really
impressive work on that
by
baker and other labs in the past but i
think that it won't get you all the way
there probably
a couple of questions uh from the online
so melissa homer says
there have been some studies using alpha
4 to predict the structure of a single
protein sequence
with no multiple sequence alignment for
example
or design
and i guess there are a couple related
questions which is
the inverse problem of protein design
you know where you
know
you know the structure you want and can
you predict the
sequence that we're getting there
and uh related to that is another
question
by laura brandt who asks could you use
alcohol to design
efficient and specific inhibitors
so there's some set of related questions
sure i mean i first want to give maybe
people a way to think about when will
alphaphil give a good answer
and um i mean i'll first say if you want
to know if alpha forward gave a good
answer you should look at the plddt and
the pae if the self-reported confidence
measures are better than
things like msa depth or any of the kind
of things that are correlated with
results but alpha tends to know whether
it's given a good answer
but the way that i think about it the
way that we think about it is there are
three inputs to alcohol right there's
the primary sequence there's the
multi-sequence alignment
and there's the set of templates
provided
and alpha fold fuses information from
all three of those
and so for many proteins the multiple
sequence alignment is strong it's a deep
alignment it takes only really about 30
alignments throughout the whole to give
a high confidence answer
and so if that's strong then alpha will
give a good answer but for some proteins
they'll have very very shallow
multi-sequence alignments maybe only one
or two sequences
but there will be a known template maybe
even a kind of weak template at the
40-50 percent identity level alpha fold
will still give a great answer because
that's strong enough for it to use that
information together with what it
understands about proteins in order to
build the structure
and for design proteins and for proteins
that have
a very small or non-existent
multi-sequence alignment and no
templates available
um then alpha fold if it's a natural
protein will mostly give a poor answer
right
it's a rare case but certainly in those
cases it tends to give a poor answer but
if it's a design it gives a very good
answer for a simple reason the sequence
is strong so alpha fold is a system with
three inputs and if any of them are
strongly encoding the structure
alpha fold will tend to find it and
we'll use that piece of information
and so that's how we tend to think about
it and in fact one of some of the
interesting cases that came up in
demise's talk of well alpha fold ignores
templates and often that's good is that
we have found kind of a priority that
the multi-sequence alignment is strong
then alpha fold will ignore the
templates even if they're 90 plus
percent templates and some cases people
have observed actually allows them to
collect correct errors in previously
solved structures uh doing that
um for though the other questions i mean
in part i've kind of answered the design
question for the design of specific
inhibitors i think you'll be in the same
sort of situation as designing for
structure now you're designing for
binding while we have a binding system
you'll still be i think
in this partial case i don't think it
will i think it will be a very useful
tool
uh
in the work but it won't certainly end
the problem
uh on its own
there's a related question to that in
the in the
chat box which is
um
have you found
places where the structures in the pdb
look wrong to half a fold you know how
many of those are there we heard in in
after demise's talk about errors made by
alpha fold so this is the sort of
reverse question
so
we've certainly i mean
so when we were developing output fold
the pdb was flawless um and and we you
know we kind of said all errors are
alpha false
um mostly and we always heard from
experimentalists well you can't trust
everything in the pdb we said sure but
you can trust it a lot more than our
half-built neural network
[Music]
although really interestingly and here
i'll mostly defer to the cast assessors
who have
put out a series of papers recently and
they do this after every cast
but talking about the different models
and what they mean and comparing the
experimental structures
and they have found some really
interesting cases where you know the
deviations were in alpha fold's favor i
mean one interesting case
um is and certainly alpha fold still
makes plenty of mistakes but there are
so but alpha folds deviations from
crystal structures are
maybe i think in their particular set of
seven proteins more than half were at
crystal contact near crystal context
which suggests maybe the solution
structure is different in at least one
case it was used to reanalyze an nmr
structure that had been deposited a new
structure was deposited so we are seeing
some of those and i think it brings a
really interesting machine learning
question of how do we now start to
jointly think about our uncertainty in
both of these methods and we see some of
this in the commentaries from the
integrative modeling community of all
these methods ultimately have to be
fused into larger biological
understanding
and it will require each of us to
understand more about those kinds of
mistakes and you know i mean another
thing that we observed in our baltimore
work is that sometimes alpha fold will
produce the structure of
not the correct bio assembly in the pdb
structure but will sometimes produce a
crystal contact and you know in some of
the cases we've looked at that's clearly
wrong but one of our hypotheses is made
in some cases surely the interfaces are
assigned incorrectly in the pdb and so
maybe alpha fold is learning to
sometimes produce
um crystal contacts and so and
and all these things i think get to this
really really interesting question where
alpha will still make certain mistakes
um absolutely still does make mistakes
but you know as computationalists we
have to think more about how to
interpret and understand the pdb data
and i think there's really interesting
things and ultimately you know
as is now that alpha fold is a widely
used tool it'll be interesting to see
the kind of influence that has on the
pdb and certainly will be part of i
think before people submit are probably
going to look and look at the deviations
and at least make sure they're supported
by say by the electronic cryo density
so yeah it's a it's
it's kind of a weird place to be for me
as a computationalist
uh certainly in structure
so another question from jamie kate is
in the progression through evil former
blocks for the difficult case
there were jumps in the score and he
wants to know what happens
in those jumps
that is a great question i'm going the
wrong direction to answer so
there is a really interesting thing that
as they observed so for example this
happens at for the most interesting jump
in our point i apologize to the online
audience what will happen at around
block 130.
and i if we go back
to the video of this and you can see the
the block counter in the bottom right
and 130 is right about here so it i
believe has docked a strand correctly
into the structure
and so what you're seeing is over the
course of
exploration it has finally found this
interface um
and then when it has it it preserves it
and so what we typically see in these
traces is jumps exactly like this
but normally monotonicity
very rarely does it find something and
then give it up
and so we see it as kind of a
progressive growing when it builds
something confident that's that's our
interpretation but we think it's
individual pieces suddenly being
understood when they weren't before it
in this case might be as simple as a
single strand
okay a couple of questions one is what
are the bottlenecks to rna structure
prediction and possibly rna protein
complexes
well
i mean
first we need we need to try it and find
out uh will be first answer the obvious
bottleneck is rna structure is much
rarer in the pdb and one one experiment
we really should do and haven't done yet
is to say how many structures would we
have needed in the pdb to do structure
prediction of a certain accuracy um
both it's kind of an interesting
historical question when had
experimentalists done their job and
computationalists hadn't finished but
also from maybe informing
how much how many rna structures do we
need and it's possible we have enough we
need to explore
but i i see that as the pro is the most
obvious bottleneck is simply the number
of structures and diversity of
structures i think as we do it now if we
don't succeed at it then we would expect
to see more bottlenecks arise
and and my understanding is with the new
with cryo-em we're likely to get many
more rna structures which will help
quite a bit
and what were the challenges with uh the
antibody interaction
uh considering
you know the problem of interface is
part you know part of the whole
problem of complexes which you've
now made some progress with so
it's very interesting and we don't i
will first give the answer of ignorance
we don't know
um
one of the things that it's not or at
least not exactly
is you know
co-evolution is much less important to
our multiple system than it is
to our single chain even our single
chain system we've shown things like
profile only um
networks are surprisingly strong um
with alpha fold
but but
for complexes you know it's a relatively
modest gain that you see by using
uh paired sequences that enable
co-evolution
so that to me mostly excludes that kind
of explanation and probably has
something to do though
with the peculiarities of how of how
antibodies are made that it must be some
different type of interface or maybe
it's a different process right they
haven't evolved together where they're
and we don't know yet it could be
interface area it could be shape
complementarity
i think it's a really interesting
question i think when we know more about
that it's definitely on our list
analyzed when we know more about that
then we will probably know more about
the multiple prediction problem
okay
well it's five o'clock so thank you very
much for
a fascinating talk and thank both of the
speakers for really a great afternoon
thank you so much